well it's back to mosques here in the
northeast of the United States I'm in
Philadelphia at the moment where the air
quality really is terrible it was Far
and Away the worst in America for much
of the day and among the worst in the
world at one point the air quality index
was over 300. that's classed as
hazardous everyone told to wear masks
and remain indoors although I have to
say very few are you can smell it you
could feel the heaviness on your chest
it's giving me a real sense of deja vu I
used to live in Beijing where the air
quality was a few years ago truly
terrible it feels just the same here now
the difference is that the Chinese were
able to improve the air quality by
shutting down Coal Power stations
improving petrol quality here though you
can't control wildfires not in the short
term at least extreme weather is
impacting well beyond where it hits